quelques mois avant sa mort survenue le
4 février 1846 dans sa maison de saint
gilles les hauts
madame desbassyns rédige son dernier
testament le 20 juin 1845 jeu mary ann
thérèse hông linh gonnot de mon bras
veuve de monsieur henri paulin panon des
bassins propriétaire demeurant à saint
gilles commune de saint-paul soussigné
voulant user de la faculté que m'accorde
l'article 1075 du code civil et fait par
le présent testament est ainsi qu'il
suit le document est conservée aux
archives départementales de la réunion
il dresse un inventaire précis de ces
biens qu elle lègue à ses neuf enfants
cinq petits enfants et six arrière
petits enfants
le testament présente l'intérêt de
décrire parmi les différents biens
lister ce qui constitue la propriété de
saint gilles les hauts
avec notamment 2 195 esclaves malgaches
cafres mais en grande majorité créole né
sur l'île bourbon
ce film d'animation met en scène une
lecture sonore partielle du testament et
lumérant cependant intégralement les non
appartenance ethnique fonctions et
valeur estimée des esclaves attaché à la
propriété